kendall jenner and devin booker are
quote hanging out after their split a
source tells e.t that the two are very
happy and quote are in a good place
right now they spent 4th of july weekend
in the hamptons together and had a
really fun time their hectic schedules
sometimes get in the way of their
relationship but they have a lot of love
for each other
it's not always easy
this update comes about a week after the
supermodel was spotted out at a
restaurant in malibu chatting with the
nba player just days after their
reported split
at the end of june news broke that
kendall and devon were going their
separate ways after two years together
at the time a source told et quote
kendall feels like they're on different
paths
and quote they have had discussions
about their future but they are not on
the same page
however a source did admit that there is
a possibility they could get back
together in the future
and based on the latest it seems as if
that time could be sooner than later
but while that's up in the air for now
what we do know is that kendall and
devon have been private about their
relationship
and in april while talking about their
new hulu series the kardashians kendall
opened up to eti about how watching her
sisters has helped her decide what she
does and doesn't want to share about her
personal life i think like a cool part
about kylie and i growing up on the show
and something that maybe we don't take
for granted is you know we got to see
things happen before we got you know
older our older sisters kind of
experienced a life that we got to view
and so just from a really young age i
think both kylie and i kind of knew what
we wanted to keep
off the show or what we wanted to keep
to ourselves and um
yeah i think that it's kind of as simple
as that and you know we learn and again
our boundaries may change one day
depending on the situation but
[Music]